please welcome bridget moynihan
oh my gosh
i've loved you in so many different
iterations and films and movies and
characters but gosh let's kick it off
with natasha i mean sex in the city uh
you're so incredible as natasha
it's like
how did you approach playing her what
was it like filming it just give me the
goods
okay so i remember going on the set and
thinking oh my god i have no idea what
i'm doing
this huge set it's like
in motion i had to just jump in like
double judge and hope to god i didn't
trip and fall and get fired all in one
day but it it worked out
i mean clearly it worked out you
became
an iconic
representation
and then there's and just like that and
natasha returns
um what was that like
oh boy was i thrilled to get that phone
call and be asked back um
and you know i there was one scene where
natasha was up in a window and she's
looking down and carrying the girls are
looking up
and i have to say there was a bunch of
takes where i was a fan and i'm just
watching them and i'm like oh my god the
shoes oh my god the dresses oh my god
they're back this is so exciting
and
i kind of think i really needed that for
my soul after two years of being in
covid and sweatpants and
just kind of sloughing around and
i needed that fashion and that color and
that pizzazz again it really
made me feel so good i kind of feel that
way about you too every single day you
show up
in the most amazing outfits
prints
vests everything you're like you're like
a daily sex in the city fashionista
so thank
you bridget thank you bridget
i i
i
i i take that uh as such a compliment
so thank you i appreciate that
um
now
is it true that your son finally watched
coyote ugly
oh you're in the room
how did that go yes
so
yeah i think it was the anniversary 20th
anniversary maybe of of um
coyote ugly
and he saw me dancing on the bar in
those
sassy leather pants that
wrapped up the crotch
and he
mow
you are so wild
and i was like
yeah that's just the script
um okay well this season of blue bloods
i'm so excited to announce and discuss
you are directing
yes
you always think like one day when i'm
when i'm
ready i would love to do this
i think i grew into it i think that
people always encouraged me
um because of whatever that they saw in
me to do it and over the years
we've really had a few women come
through
from different departments
and
earn their wings in the directing see
you know portion of it and i've watched
them go up through the ranks
and they've always suggested always
supported me and so i finally got the
opportunity and
i had i mean i just almost started
crying when i saw that photo i had such
an incredible
experience
and it feels really
feels really great to take on this new
challenge and go
to this next level in this next step
and
it's a first and i just i i just turned
50.
and it just feels really good to be
doing something new and have a new
challenge in this next you know
decade congratulations on that truly
thank you like may we all find the
courage to take it higher
and everybody be sure to watch blue
bloods fridays at 10 pm eastern on cbs
bridget thank you so much
[Music]